this is our fourth year at comic-con
[Applause]
that's right I've been coming to
comic-con for four years or to put that
in terms everyone at comic-con
understands 17 spider-man movies
congratulations they now reboot them
halfway through the movie yeah get
another guy in there yeah so great to be
in San Diego I love San Diego
you know what I like about San Diego
with all that's going on in America it's
comforting to know it would only take 15
minutes to drive to another country
isn't that nice seriously if stuff goes
to [ __ ] you know in Washington we could
all get on one bird scooter and get the
hell out of here
[Applause]
[Applause]
man I'm sick of the pose people are
forced into you on a bird scooter you
got to get the little turn of the leg
there yeah you'll lighten it there you
go there isn't it that right there look
at my ass this is cool tickets to this
year's Comic Con sold out in about an
hour an hour yeah last time something
sold out that fast it was Donald Trump
in Helsinki now folks
I love the people you meet at comic-con
just walking around yeah this lovely
people I met a lot of interesting people
today I met people that can understand
Vulcan Dothraki and elvish get this I
even met someone who can understand the
plot of Westworld
I was lost at the fourth episode a lot
to see here at Comic Con in Hall H
they're displaying a replica of the
Millennium Falcon cockpit used in the
Star Wars movie solo yeah the cockpit
seats too just like the movie theaters
that showed solo
[Applause]
you're like hey come on it was pretty
good on the fifth Ewing we knew when we
wrote that joke that's gonna get the
crowd half very happy half furious
just like our country right now speaking
of star wars here in San Diego's Balboa
Park a group of Star Wars fans scheduled
a lightsaber battle as always there were
no winners
you
you